- My TikTok game got stronger.
Check out my videos,
but we're actually going to
watch other people's videos.
Bewoop!
- You are at risk of Type II diabetes.
I think it possibly might
be a yeast infection,
yeast infection.
- Imagine that's how I
delivered news to my patients.
- The best treatment option
is probably fungal cream and-
- Fungal cream for what?
For the yeast infection?
I mean, we could just
give a single pill here.
I don't know what's happening,
but it is good musical theater.
- [Sam] What's a musical theater diagnosis
you can give a patient.
- Pneumonia.
Benign prostatic hyperplasia.
- Knock, knock big (indistinct).
What's up, big dog.
So look, the abdominal pain
you came in with sucks, right?
So we sent you down for the scans, right?
And I mean, the scans came back
and they're certainly not bussin'.
(Mike laughs)
- I'm not going to lie.
I've seen residents talk
like this amongst each other.
And I kind of laugh because
I'm getting too old for it.
- Bussin'?
- Yeah, no cap like high key, big yikes.
- Dude, I don't know what you're saying.
- All right, bet.
Big facts.
But no, we're gonna get you down to ER.
- Big facts, no printer.
Even on my conversations with patients,
it doesn't get this crazy.
- I'm doing CPR to the tablet.
- Aw, she's doing chest compressions.
Chest compressions, chest compressions.
- Wait, do you know they
did surgery on a grape?
- Aww, how did she know?
That's so good.
She's watching the good content.
It doesn't work on iPads.
- [Narrator] Fantastic.
- Don't use Q-tips in your ears!
Ahh!
Because you push the ear wax further back
and then I'm going to
have to operate on you,
like I did Jen Selter.
Check out my TikTok of me doing so.
- Q-tips just push all the
earwax in deeper, right?
I mean, yeah, but what
else am I supposed to do?
Well, you can let me put this straw
of hydrogen peroxide in it.
Why?
- It melts it and then it
allows us to naturally come out.
Or sometimes you could just
shoot a little soapy water
in there or something and clean it out.
- 'Cause it'll actually
loosen up the ear wax
and clean out your ear.
No, this is the weirdest thing ever.
Ahh!
- You don't actually have to
put the straw in your head.
You just let the fluid
leak out into your ear.
- When I was a kid, I
discovered this crazy talent.
And I was examined by doctors,
they said it was almost superhuman-like.
When I drink a glass of water
and I move my lips up and down,
I can heat it up into water vapor.
- What?!
No, I don't believe that.
You can't trust anything you see online
unless it's happening
directly in front of me.
And I know his name is not David Blaine
or a famous magician.
Water vapor, that's boiling.
He boils it?
Boils it?
(Mike speaking gibberish)
- How does this...
Turn into this?
- Oh my god.
No, I'm hopeful that that is just an X-ray
of a Buzz Lightyear behind a person.
Because inside of a person,
it has edges, his wings.
To infinity and beyond!
Oh my God.
What is happening here?
Is this acupuncture?
This feels largely unnecessary.
No, you can't put the thing on his head.
You can't do it.
Oh, don't do it.
That doesn't look comfortable.
The problem with this is it's
going through the muscle.
So if you're trying to make
some kind of facial expression,
imagine you try and move
and all the needles, ahhh.
- If you put two arms up,
then put one arm down
and then push that arm backwards twice.
That arm will become much
longer than the other arm.
- No, it didn't work.
You can't see it,
but I promise you it doesn't work
unless you just loosened it up
or the other arm got tired or something.
I dunno.
This is medical misinformation.
- If you pinch your arm 10 times,
close your eyes and then touch your elbow.
You won't feel anything.
- These are- I don't understand.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
I still feel everything.
I feel my hand.
It doesn't even make sense.
The body's quite capable of
feeling pinches and touches.
Before Keto.
Sad.
After Keto.
No, Keto is not a miracle potion.
Yes, it does help people get
some short-term weight loss.
Some people really love it,
but medically, it's not
miraculous, as people say.
- All right, let's just talk about it.
Who's the most important organ?
- It's definitely me because-
- It's the brain.
We did the poll, the brain.
- ...everything to do, y'all
can't think for yourself.
- That's true.
- But if I didn't pump blood to you,
you wouldn't be able to function though.
- That's true.
- But I have to tell you
to pump blood though.
- But You wouldn't be able
to tell me to pump blood
if I didn't pump blood to you.
- Yeah, but that's like
the chicken before the egg.
Without the brain, the
heart's not pumping.
And when the heart pumps,
the brain can continue to function.
But the brain needs to be there
to start the process first.
Yes, in trauma protocol,
we try and save the lungs and the heart.
Without the brain, nothing's a cooking.
I like the brain.
I think the brain is magical.
I think it's beautiful.
I think it's a fun organ.
I like to touch it.
Not while it's in people's
heads, but in cadavers,
when you're learning about them.
- You've been using you ears wrong.
Right and left actually
have different functions.
- No they don't!
- If you're somewhere loud
and trying to hear what someone is saying,
you're more likely to succeed-
- Ah no, all of this is nonsense.
This is- cool.
That looks like a ganglion cyst.
And I have drained those.
I've also taken those out.
(book whacks hand)
- Ow!
- Oh, don't do that.
- [Sam] Bear.
- Is that dog's name Bear?
He's literally slapping
me with his tongue.
You think he's hyperventilating?
Oh my god, so mean.
Just standing there, waiting for someone
to take it off my face.
Oh baby.
It's going to poop or fart.
(baby farts)
It's a farty baby.
We do that to babies.
It looks like torture, but
babies actually really like it.
Ben Dover psychiatrist.
- Uh, Doctor, there's a patient out here
saying he's turning invisible.
- Tell him I can't see him now.
- He also said, he's shrinking.
- Well, he's going to have
to be a little patient.
(Mike laughs)
- That's really good.
It's a little patient.
Oh, why is this dog so scared
of the nail clippers though?
Aww no, puppy.
Noooooo.
That must mean they
did it wrong last time.
'Cause it's not supposed to hurt.
When I do it to Bear,
he doesn't even care.
He's just like-
(Mike blows raspberry)
- Dude, I feel so nauseous.
Try smelling this.
- Oh alcohol gross.
- What the (beep) is this?
Rubbing alcohol.
Still feel nauseous?
Actually, no.
Thanks.
- What?
- I feel like I'm gonna throw up.
Start humming.
(girl humming)
- What?
- I don't have to throw up anymore.
My nose won't stop running.
Easy trick to clear your sinuses
is hold your tongue to
the roof of your mouth
and then press your
thumb to your forehead.
You know too much.
- Dude, you don't know too much
'cause all of that is fake news.
I'm sorry.
You had a good one with the ears.
Not a good one here.
- Unfortunately you've tested positive
for a plethora of diseases.
- Oh my god.
Am I going to die?
- Firstly, you have 'monoenicoliokich.'
- 'Moleonicolicolich.'
A little mononucleosis.
- 'Menintits.'
- What, is that a nipple issue?
- Meningitis?
- Rabbis.
(Mike laughs)
- Rabies.
- 'Deearia.'
- 'Deearia!'
- Gimme that.
You've been mispronouncing all of these.
- The way you say these differentiates on
where you went to medical school.
- Rabies, not rabbis.
Mononucleosis, not 'monoenicoliokich.'
- 'Yo kich.'
- Are you even a doctor?
- That's confidential.
- It's not confidential.
He could look that up.
- I am never donating blood again ever.
The very second you walk in the door,
question after question.
Where did you get it?
Why is it in a bucket?
Do ya (beep) want it or don't ya?
(Mike laughs)
- That is not where I
thought that would go.
Yeah, donate blood in a bucket.
That's not how it works.
- Did you know that sometimes
when a woman's appendix burst,
they ignore it because it's
the same as a period cramp.
- Well, they don't ignore it.
Doctors sometimes ignore
it because they think
it's a period cramp and they just blame it
on the menstrual cycle.
And that's horribly wrong.
- I'm convinced women are aliens.
The pain tolerance!
They know everything!
They know when you're lying!
- High emotional intelligence
and being disbelieved
by the medical system.
This is facts.
It actually does happen quite often.
- Put a finger down if one day you woke up
with what you thought
was a late season flu
and then a couple hours
later you developed
some Charlie horses in your legs.
But instead of these Charlie horses
lasting only a couple of minutes,
they ended up lasting six hours.
And when you got to the ER,
you didn't look like an emergency case
because you're a healthy 23 year old,
you got hot and you pulled
some blankets off your legs,
and your dad asked you
what was on your leg
and you look down and it
looked like a giant bruise
and it wasn't there a couple of hours ago.
So your husband go gets the ER doctor.
And then you don't remember
anything for two weeks.
And when you woke up, you were
missing your entire left leg
and you had a giant
scar on your right arm.
- What was the diagnosis?
Looked it up.
Necrotizing fasciitis.
Brutal, brutal condition.
Terrible story.
But this is prime example of PTG.
Post-traumatic growth.
Sharing a story, so
others don't feel alone.
Positivity, humor, I'm
a fan, I'm watching.
This TikTok grandma over here
has some medical questions
and has some medical statements.
Are they real?
Are they not?
We're going to discuss it here.
Click here to check that out.
And while you do that,
stay happy and healthy.
Click it.
Grandma.
TikTok grandma.
GB.